Distinguished Lecture my name is Peter
Butler and I'm the Associate Director of
the Simon's Institute for the theory of
computing thanks for joining us we
established this series to celebrate the
role of Simon's Institute founding
director dick Carr in establishing the
theory of theoretical computer science
in formulating at central problems and
in contributing stunning results in the
areas of computational complexity and
algorithms the series features visionary
leaders in the field of theoretical
computer science and is geared towards a
broad scientific audience we're grateful
to the many contributors to the Richard
M Karp Fund who've made this series
possible so today I'm delighted to
welcome our speaker Henri un Henri is an
assistant professor of computer science
and mathematics at the University of
Toronto
where his member of the CS theory group
and the Center for quantum information
and quantum control he's also an
affiliate member of the Institute for
quantum computing at the University of
Waterloo and a recipient of the Google
quantum research award Henry was a
postdoctoral researcher here at Berkeley
working with Ramesh Vaz irani he holds a
PhD from MIT where he was assignments
graduate fellow in theoretical computer
science and a recipient of the NSF
graduate fellowship and Henry is a
participant in the Simas Institute
spring 2020 program on the quantum wave
in computing his research focuses on the
interplay between quantum computing
complexity theory cryptography and
information theory and he's one of the
discoverers of a breakthrough result
from January this year on the
computational power of quantum
entanglement which has deservingly
generated an enormous amount of
excitement being widely lauded as a
historic achievement in complexity
theory and has implications for
foundations of quantum physics and for
the theory of operator algebras so we're
really delighted to have Henry telling
us about this breakthrough his talk
today is entitled a tale of Turing
machines quantum entangled particles and
operator algebras and a quick reminder
if you'd like to ask a question please
post it onto the chat so welcome Henry
thanks Peter for the introduction let me
share my screen can everyone see
looks good okay so so hi everyone I hope
you're all staying safe and keeping well
these days and thanks for tuning in I'm
really honored and excited to have this
chance to tell you about a seemingly
unlikely story about how some ideas from
three very different fields of study
recently came together to answer some
seemingly unrelated mysteries so the
three fields that I mean are the theory
of computing quantum physics and
operator algebras which is a branch of
pure mathematics and you know these
fields are quite different in nature and
in character and here are some of their
guiding questions you know in the theory
of computing an important question is is
it harder for a computer to search for
solutions than verify them in quantum
physics a big question is can it quantum
entanglement be explained by classical
physics and in the theory of operator
algebras people ask what is the
mathematical structure of our operators
on Hilbert space and it might be hard to
imagine how these questions could
remotely be related to each other so in
the January of this year which probably
seems like forever ago for many of us my
collaborator Chang Feng Jian in at Arjun
Toma vidiq and John Wright posted a
paper to archive called
MIP star equals re and this title might
seem very obscure it claims the
equivalence of two different complexity
classes but it indeed represents a
convergence of these ideas from these
three fields so in this talk I'm going
to trace through each of these paths
which interestingly had a common
starting point nearly a century ago
these story lines individually diverge
and flourish but meet again at MIP star
so this is not going to be a super
technical talk so I won't assume that
you know anything about complexity
theory or quantum physics or operator
algebras
but if anything
super unclear you know like Peter said
please feel free to ask in the chat and
I'll try to answer them okay so let's
get started with quantum physics so our
story starts in the 1930s and let's set
the scene so the the Great Depression is
you know happening swing jazz was in its
heyday and a lot was happening in
science so for one the theory of quantum
mechanics was taking its modern form it
was just gaining widespread acceptance
and physicists around the world we're
starting to get used to the many
counterintuitive features of this new
explanation of nature of how the
universe works at the smallest scales
for example you know things could be in
two states at the same time there's this
thing like wave particle duality there's
this uncertainty principle and one thing
that really stood out for its weirdness
is this phenomenon of quantum
entanglement so what is it well imagine
that you have these two particles you
know you can think of them as maybe
being electrons that at one point we're
very close to each other and and perhaps
interacted with each other but then
imagine that you separated them maybe
you put them out in you know different
galaxies millions of light-years apart
so quantum physics says that the state
of these faraway particles can be linked
in such a way that if people in these
different galaxies simultaneously
measured you know these particles using
local measurements you know on each of
these particles the measurement results
would show some very strange
correlations almost as if one particle
could instantaneously influence the
other and when I say almost if I mean
that you actually can't use these
particles to send signals faster than
the speed of light but when you take the
results of the measurements and bring
them together
the exhibit correlations that just look
very strange and so these particles are
said to be quantum entangled
Albert Einstein was famously disturbed
by implications of quantum entanglement
there's a popular misconception that
Einstein didn't understand quantum
physics but on the contrary he
understood it extremely well it was
crystal clear to him for example that
quantum entanglement couldn't be used to
send signals faster than the speed of
light but he was really bothered by what
the theory of quantum physics looked
like you know he said if you looked at
the mathematical equations describing
how these two faraway particles behave
and and what happens when you measure
them the equations strongly suggest you
know some sort of story of instantaneous
spooky action going on even though it
doesn't really mad at fessed itself
operationally in the real world so you
know this really offended Einstein's
philosophical beliefs and in a famous
1935 paper by Einstein Podolsky and
Rosen
he and his co-authors put forth an
argument that there should be a nicer
theory of physics that reproduces the
same predictions of quantum mechanics
but it's formulated in a local classical
way so by local I mean that it doesn't
allow instantaneous action at a distance
and by classical I essentially mean a
deterministic model of nature
it took nearly 30 years before you know
people realize that you know there's no
hope for for Einsteins dream so a
physicist named John Bell came along and
proved something called Bell's theorem
which says that EPR dream of a local
classical description of quantum
mechanics is impossible and the way that
John Bell proved this was through an
ingenious thought experiment so I'll
describe a modern reformulations of
Bell's thought experiment through
something called the CH SH game so in
this game there's someone named the
verifier who's in the middle here and a
verifier is some completely classical
being you know like you or me and the
verifier interacts with two players that
are cooperating with each other and
since I'm a computer scientist I'm going
to call these players Alice and Bob and
we'll assume that Alice and Bob can't
communicate with each other we can maybe
enforce that through spatial separation
you know they can't talk to each other
during the course of this game but
instead they only talk to the verifier
in the middle and when the game starts
the verifier will choose two random bits
x and y and send X to Alice and a bit
wide to Bob so when they receive these
input bits they have to respond with the
answers so Alice has to produce an
answered bit a and Bob has to produce an
answer bit B and they send their answers
back to the verifier and the players win
if the sum of their answer bits is equal
to the product of their question bits so
so that's it that's you know it's a
single round game it's very simple so
given this game we can ask you know if
Alice and Bob want to maximize their
chances of winning this game what
strategy should they employ so this
depends on what your model of physics is
so if the players behave according to a
local classical theory of physics then
their optimal winning probability is
that most 75% and this is easy to
achieve Allison
for example it can always output zero
regardless of the questions they
received and this will satisfy the
winning condition 3/4 of the time let's
see that there was a there's a question
so on the other hand if Alice and Bob
takes advantage of quantum physics they
can you know before the game starts they
can you know get together and prepare a
strategy that uses quantum entanglement
to gain an advantage so they could you
know perhaps use some fancy lab
equipment to prepare two particles in a
quantum entangled state they each take
one particle each and separate from each
other and during the game depending on
their questions that were asked of them
by the verifier depending on their
inputs how they're perform some local
measurement on their particle and report
the measurement outcome as their answer
and there is a quantum strategy by which
Alice and Bob can win this game with a
strictly higher probability 85% of the
time so quantum physics predicts this
higher winning probability than what a
local classical physical theory would so
you know put together this is how John
Bell deduced his theorem you know local
classical physics cannot reproduce all
predictions of quantum mechanics it's a
fundamentally non classical description
of nature so the chssh game is not just
a thought experiment it's been
experimentally tested many times over
the years a high-profile example of this
is an experiment that was conducted at
tu Delft in the Netherlands so here's a
picture of their campus and the way they
conducted this experiment is they had a
verifier place in the middle
they had Alice and Bob which are really
just some pieces of a lab equipment
separated over a kilometer apart and you
know Alice and Bob have some you know
they share some quantum entangled
particles but then when they play the CH
SH game with this verifier they play the
game so fast that they don't have time
to send signals to each other you know
even
if the unity transmitted light signals
so this is how you enforce the no
communication constraint between Alice
and Bob you know they played this game
and they you know observe a winning
probability that's strictly greater than
75% so even if you don't know anything
about quantum mechanics or you know you
don't believe in quantum mechanics from
this experiment you're forced to
conclude that whatever Alice and Bob are
doing they can't be doing something that
obeys a local classical theory of
physics on the other hand quantum
mechanics does give accurate predictions
of the behavior of Alice and Bob so this
simple game gives a way to verify the
quantum nature of of our world so you
know since the days of Einstein and John
Bell we've learned then you know some of
nature's strangest phenomenons such as
super conductivity or super fluidity are
fundamentally due to large numbers of
particles that are all entangled with
each other this does this also believe
that you know this fantastic phenomenon
of black hole evaporation is also you
know explained by quantum entanglement
and there's also something you know
there's a lot of evidence that something
much more mundane namely photosynthesis
also takes advantage of entanglement to
more efficiently convert sunlight into
chemical energy you know so the point is
you know the world that we live in it
seems to be you know it's governed by
this very non classical theory of nature
in and John bells experiment his thought
experiment really you know gave us the
kind of a very solid proof that you know
this is the case
you
so now let me turn to the story of
awkward your algebra
okay so it looks like Sayid asks is
there a simple way to explain the hidden
variable theory does the hidden variable
theory try to explain everything through
classical correlations right so I didn't
mention what a hidden variable theory is
but this is what I it's another name for
a local classical theory of physics and
yes it it's just you know they're one in
the same a hidden variable theory is one
where you just have classical
correlations between all measurement
outcomes okay so you know let's go
the 1930s and as I mentioned earlier
quantum mechanics was just gaining
widespread acceptance but for a while it
was in terrible mathematical shape you
know full of inconsistencies and it'll
define concepts so you know the the
eminent mathematician John von Neumann
set out to fix this situation and in
1932 he was able to put quantum
mechanics on a firm mathematical
foundation and he developed an extremely
elegant language for it
you know this language says that quantum
states are described by factors in a
complex Hilbert space and measurements
are described by linear operators on
that space and this language is what you
know quantum information scientists like
myself and physicists everywhere still
used today and you know this was already
an illustrious contribution by von
Neumann one of many for him but von
Neumann realized there is much more to
be said about operators on Hilbert
spaces so over the next decade von
Neumann and his co-author Francis Murray
put out a series of papers studying
these operators and this launched the
field of operator algebra
you
so the field of operator Alturas is a
very deep subject in pure mathematics
and it reveals a zoo of objects with
immense complexity and structure and
just like how ologists try to classify
you know the diversity of organisms out
there operator algebra is also want to
classify all these abstract animals that
roam around the mathematic mathematical
landscape so in particular one of the
most important goals of the field is to
classify something called von Neumann
factors and they're broadly classified
into three species called type 1 2 and 3
and within each type there are
subspecies so the subspecies of type 1
factors were completely categorized and
understood by murray and von neumann in
their you know the initial sequence of
papers but that left open the question
of well how do type 2 and type 3 factors
behave and really progress stalled for
quite some time but in the 1970s there
was you know a huge amount of progress
led by the mathematician Elaine Khan and
he won the Fields Medal in part for
giving a classification of type 3
factors
and in one of his papers that was
written in 1976 Alain cons makes kind of
a casual remark about something called
type tou1 factors he was focused on
studying a particular breed of animal
called injective type tou1 factors but
he says you know he thinks that there
should be some embedding property that
ought to hold for all type tou1 factors
not just the injected ones okay and this
throwaway line in his paper became known
as the Khan embedding conjecture and you
know he it's it's he didn't solve this
and I won't describe the the precise
statement of what the common betting
conjecture says but roughly speaking it
asks if these type tou1 factors which in
general are these really abstract
infinite dimensional objects could they
be approximately understood in terms of
something much more concrete which are
finite dimensional matrices
and over the years you know this
embedding conjecture became more and
more significant because researchers
discovered many equivalent formulations
and consequences of the Khan embedding
conjecture across different areas of
mathematics
so now let me turn to the third thread
which is computer science so once again
let's go back to the 1930s and in 1936
Alan Turing proposed the concept of a
universal computing machine known as the
universal Turing machine it's a machine
that can simulate any other computing
device and you know today it's in
retrospect it's almost an obvious and
simple concepts it's one of the most
powerful ideas in science it's the idea
that from you know a few simple rules
you can obtain Universal computation and
it often doesn't matter what simple
rules those are it's it's very hard to
avoid this phenomenon of universality
and in his paper where he introduced his
machine turning shows that there's a
problem that this Universal machine
can't solve which is to determine which
Turing machines halts and which ones run
forever and he proved that there's no
algorithm you know to solve this problem
and he gave a very clever argument that
you know today every undergraduate and
computer science learns and one of the
reasons that he proved this was you know
he wanted to show that there's no
automatic procedure to decide which
mathematical statements have proves you
know gertle showed about ten years
earlier that there are mathematical
statements which you know you can't
there's no proof of whether they're true
or false and turning in some sense
followed up on that and proved that you
know there's no procedure to determine
which mathematical statements have
proofs or or not and this answered a big
open question posed by you know the
mathematician David Hilbert at the
beginning of the 20th century
so let's fast forward 40 years in the
1970s Steve cook asked to follow a
question of the halting problem you know
even though we you know we we know that
we can't determine if a mathematical
statement has a proof if I guarantee you
that a mathematical statement has a
short proof that you can quickly verify
can you then quickly find one and you
know this is the P versus NP question
and it motivated cooks discovery of NP
completeness and at its heart you know
the P versus NP question is about the
it's the difference it's about the
difference between checking approved
versus finding one and I think for many
of us we all have this gut feeling that
there is a huge difference it's much
easier to verify a solution to a problem
than to find the solution yourself and
of course shortly afterwards in his
famous paper about 21 np-complete
problems Richard Karp showed us that you
know cooks question about proof checking
versus proof finding is a much bigger
phenomenon than than just mathematical
proofs NP completeness and the P versus
NP question shows up everywhere in
computing so it didn't take long for
people to realize that you know this P
versus NP question is incredibly
difficult it's it's still open today so
you know starting in the 1980s Reacher's
started branching out you know to come
up with a dazzling array of new ideas
concepts and models and they're out of
computer science and inspired by this P
versus NP question people kept asking
well what is a proof what does it mean
and before the 1980s you know a
mathematical proof meant some static you
know piece of static test text that you
sequentially check using formal
deterministic rules and the types of
statements that you can verify using
this traditional notion of proof are
exactly solutions to problems in the
class NP you know this is the definition
of NP but starting in the the 1980s
computer scientists began boldly
reconsidering what a proof could be
a proof doesn't have to be static it can
be interactive it can be zero knowledge
probabilistically checkable it could be
quantum it can be economically rational
so you know that's just the sort of the
tip of the iceberg and I'm gonna focus
on the notion of an interactive proof
which was Co invented by Shafi
Goldwasser Sylvia McCauley in Charlie
Rock off and the motivation for
interactive proofs comes from our common
experience that it's much easier to
learn something complicated if you get
to interactively talk to a teacher
rather than learning it by reading a
book or you know reading the paper by
yourself so in an interactive proof you
know we have a verifier who wants to
determine if some statement X is true an
example of such a statement X could be
maybe someone hands you to grasp G&H and
they claim they're non isomorphic or
maybe some number is a composite number
or maybe some boolean formula is not
satisfiable right and and the verifier
wants to know which of these statements
are true and maybe you know for these
statements to provide a static proof
would take way too long you know for
example imagine trying to prove to
someone that two graphs G and H are non
isomorphic right in general we don't
know of any succeed short proof of this
fact but maybe by interrogating and you
know someone who's all-powerful and
all-knowing it's possible to learn
whether a statement is true or not so in
this model the verifier gets to
interactively talk to this prove ER who
knows everything but maybe the the
provers not trustworthy and the verify
wants to conduct a conversation with
this prove ER where if the statement X
is indeed true then the prover can
convince the verifier of this fact in
polynomial time and with high
probability but if X is false then no
matter what the prover says the verifier
should realize that X is false and
reject with high probability so this is
what an interactive proof is
so you know people define this notion
this model of proof and and then you can
start to ask well in this new notion
what statements X can be verified
efficiently and one of the most
important results in complexity theory
is the IP equals P space theorem so IP
stands for interactive proofs and P
space stands for the the class of
problems that are solvable in polynomial
space so it means that the statements X
that you can verify interactively are
the ones that are solutions to P space
problems and these are extremely complex
problems they include np-complete
problems but also ones that we believe
to be much harder and it really
demonstrates that interactivity is a
powerful resource for verification
people also ask well what if the
verifier you know can interrogate
multiple provers you know why not yeah
you know why stop with one prove or what
if we have multiple provers so you know
in this model we have these two provers
who are all powerful but we have to have
a constraint between them in order to
make this model interesting so we assume
that the provers can't communicate with
each other so you know what's the point
of this you know I said that these
provers are all knowing and all powerful
computational beings so why would two be
different from one well the difference
is that the verifier now has extra
leverage it gets to put these provers
into separate rooms and cross
interrogate them to see if the provers
are trying to make a false claim
essentially the verifier Claes the
provers against each other and this
extra leverage turns out to be very
powerful so at the same time as the IP
equals peace base theorem but bye for
now Luna proved that the class of you
know the class MIP which is the set of
problems that can be solved in the multi
prove or proofs model is equal to NX
which is non-deterministic exponential
time so in other words you can verify in
polynomial time solutions to
exponentially large NP problems
so the IP equals P space and M IP equals
n X theorems in the early 90s quickly
led to in my opinion one of the most
wonderful results in computer science
which is that probabilistically
checkable proofs theorem or the PCP
theorem and it says that if you have a
static proof for a statement X you can
efficiently transform that proof into a
format where this proof can be verified
by only examining constantly many bits
of the proof at random and this constant
is independent of the overall length of
the proof so in other words if someone
wrote a super-long mathematical proof of
say you know the Riemann hypothesis or
the ABC conjecture in principle you can
ask them to format this proof in such a
way that you can verify its correctness
by looking at only three random
locations in the proof so this is a very
remarkable result that opened up a
number of subfields in theoretical
computer science
okay so you know I've taken us through a
pretty expansive tour of many different
ideas and in many different fields so
now let's see how they all come together
to bring us to MIP star equals re so
about 15 years ago some computer
scientists working at the intersection
between complexity theory and quantum
information no Richard Klee Peter Hoyer
bent owner John macho's notice that
Bell's experiment which I described you
know maybe 10 minutes ago
looks awfully like an interactive proof
ok so remember this thsh game that i
described you know played between a
verifier and two non commuting player
non communicating players named Alice
and Bob and just now I talked about this
model of interactive proofs between a
verifier and two non communicating
approvers and when you see these two
pictures you know your first reaction
should be you know to start rubbing your
chin and wonder if there's a deeper
connection between these two settings so
you know these four computers
said well maybe we can think of these
games like the CH sh game in the context
of interactive crews and this motivated
them to define this model of quantum
multi proven interactive proofs so here
there are multiple provers so let's say
to prove errs they interact with the
verifier but now the provers are allowed
to share quantum entangled particles so
they still can't communicate but when
they interact with the verifier they can
possibly utilize their entanglement to
correlate their answers in stronger ways
than would be possible if the provers
were unentangled know for now we'll
assume that the the verifier is still
classical so in this expanded model we
can ask the same questions
what statements X can be verified with
these now entangled provers and we still
want the property that if the statement
X is true we want to be convinced by
these entangled provers but if X is
false then no matter what these provers
say even using the help of entanglement
the verifier should be able to realize
that X is false and reject with high
probability so this model motivates this
class MIP star and this represents the
problems whose solutions can be verified
in this model so what's the complexity
of MIP star oh this is tied to the
following question is there an algorithm
to approximate optimal winning
probabilities for non-local games so you
know what does that mean well let's
recall the the CH SH game it's you know
here's a recap of what it is it's you
know you have some questions some
answers and some winning conditions and
there's this optimal winning probability
for quantum players which is this eighty
five point four percent and you can
consider well well let's generalize this
we don't necessarily have to have these
types of questions or this winning
condition we can consider a general game
G which consists of two pieces of
information one which is a distribution
new over questions x and y that you ask
to the players they don't have to be
bits they can be strings with a larger
size
their answers also don't have to be bits
there's some function D that tells you
what combinations of questions and
answers are allowed you know allow the
players to win so if you specify a
general non-local game G like this you
can ask well what is the optimal success
probability for our two players who
share quantum entanglement in this game
okay you allow the two players to choose
any entangled strategy that they like
you know they know the the rules of the
game beforehand and they just want to
maximize this probability so I'll denote
this by ox G so since we're thinking of
things in terms of complexity theory we
can ask is there a general algorithm to
compute this optimal success probability
even approximately
so you know here I'm not even asking if
there's a fast algorithm I'm asking if
there's any algorithm to solve this
problem and you know when you think
about this question you say well you
know how hard could this be to just come
up with anything you know some algorithm
you know you might try some trivial
brute force approach you know maybe
let's just try to enumerate over all
possible quantum strategies for Alice
and Bob well you know you run into a
couple of issues here I mean the first
you know the space of quantum strategies
is continuous right so in some sense
there's infinitely many how do you
enumerate over these infinitely many
using an algorithm
well the continuous part of this is not
such a big deal because you can
discretize the space of quantum
strategies and search over to this
discretization and and you can come up
with an approximate answer possibly the
bigger problem is that you know the
space is infinite in a different way
which is you know when we're considering
the space of quantum strategies there's
no a priori bound on the number of
entangled particles or qubits that Alice
and Bob could share right they can
choose to share you know two qubits of
entanglement you know three qubits 100
cubits or more you know a gazillion and
if someone walked up to you with you
know an arbitrary non-local game gee you
wouldn't necessarily know a priori how
many qubits of entanglement they would
need to play optimally or nearly
optimally right so you know if you're
writing this algorithm it would you
would start searching over you know two
qubit strategies three cubed strategies
and so on but you wouldn't know where to
stop necessarily so it's kind of
puzzling what you have you know how we
can't even come up with a trivial
algorithm to approximate this optimal
winning probability and it turns out
that people realize maybe you know ten
years ago that this question connects to
some very deep questions in mathematics
namely this Khan embedding conjecture
that I mentioned earlier turns out
that if the cotton bedding conjecture
were true it implies the existence of an
algorithm which I'll call game solver to
approximate this op G for all non local
games G and this connection is really
due to a long sequence of results from
different fields the you know the the
first link in this bridge is in the 90s
people realized that the Khan embedding
conjecture is equivalent to something
called Kirsch burrs conjecture in in the
realm of C star algebras and then 10
years ago people realize that Kira's
conjecture is equivalent to a problem in
quantum information theory called
Saracens problem and then people then
realize that this positive answer to
Saracens problem implies the existence
of an algorithm so it's it's a number of
results that have to to follow in the
place before people realize this
connection so what is this algorithm
I'll describe it to you and it's
comprised of two procedures I'll call
them you know the the first procedure
search from below and the second
procedure search from above so let me
start with the algorithm search from
below so what does it do well it's a
procedure that computes an infinite
sequence of numbers so it by itself it
doesn't halt and the sequence of numbers
is numbers alpha 1 less than alpha 2
less than alpha 3 and so on the sequence
is non-decreasing and they're all lower
bounds on the optimum winning
probability of a particular non-local
game yeah you know the non-local game
that you started with so what is alpha D
it's the best success probability that
you can achieve with D cubed D cubed
strategy so you fix the number of
particles that you allow Alice and Bob
to share and you ask well what is their
best success probability with those
number of qubits
and for fixed D this number alpha D is
computable it's approximable and you can
do it for example by enumerator or in an
epsilon net 'm over the space of d cubed
strategies and and you can search over
this in finite time and one thing that's
you know not too hard to prove as you
can show that as d increases
goes to infinity this sequence alpha d
does eventually approach the the optimum
winning probability the issue is you
just don't know how fast so that's the
search form below procedure now what
about the search form above procedure it
also computes an infinite sequence of
numbers beta 1 beta 2 beta 3 that's now
non-increasing so it eventually
decreases and there are all upper bounds
on this optimum winning probability and
what is beta d beta D is the best upper
bound on opt G that you can certify
using degree D sums of squares of non
commutative polynomials so this sounds
pretty abstract the important thing to
know is that beta D is also computable
if you can run a semi definite program
to solve this to compute an
approximation of beta D
and as you increase D the sequence of
numbers you know they're all upper
bounds on op G but assuming the Khan
embedding conjecture they actually
converge to op G so now we can put these
two procedures together and this gives
us a candidate algorithm to solve you
know op G for for all G you basically
run these two procedures in parallel and
if any any point the numbers alpha D and
beta D get within some epsilon then you
know you've honed in the correct value
you know the optimum value of this game
right because it's sandwiched between
these two sequences so if the common
embedding conjecture is true then these
two sequences do converge and then
you've found this OP G so that's the
connection between this conjecture and
this question of whether there's an
algorithm to to solve this problem so
you know given this you might say well
why let's just try to prove the the Khan
embedding conjecture and then we would
have an algorithm so this result mi p
star equals re shows the following it
shows that there's a computable
reduction from Turing machines to
non-local games where if you start with
the Turing machine M you can transform
it into a non-local game G sub M with
the property that if you ran this turing
machine m and it eventually halts this
is reflected in the this op g is up to
you will turn out b1 there's a strategy
for these players in this game to win
with probability one on the other hand
if this Turing machine never halts then
op G is at most say point zero one this
is the the best that any quantum
strategy can do and this point zero one
is not such an important number it just
has to be you know it can be any
constant that's strictly less than one
so you know what are the consequences
well it means that you know this game
solver can't be used this game Sol
rather than describe it can't be used to
approximate this optimum winning
probability for all non-local games
because otherwise it could be used to
solve the halting problem right this
reduction shows that if you could
distinguish between you know these you
know if you can approximate this off to
a winning probability you could tell
whether the original Turing machine
halted or not you know but assuming this
con betting conjecture this algorithm
should succeed for all G and so the
conclusion is that the this conjecture
must be false
so I won't have much time to go into the
proof but let me say some words about it
and it'll sort of present the proof from
a thousand miles away you know so recall
this PCP theorem that I mentioned and it
says that proofs of statements you know
mathematical statements can be written
in a way that can be checked by
examining only a constant number of
random locations and a proof so the idea
behind MIP star equals REE in some sense
is to recursively iterate the PCP
theorem an arbitrary number of times and
you know in some vague sense what this
recursive PCP theorem is is trying to do
it is trying to efficiently verify that
a complicated verifier has verified an
even more complex verifier that has you
know and so on right so there's it's
kind of like a tongue twister but you
know it's you know verifying the
verification procedure of a verifier
that you know is doing the same thing
recursively so this is what you would
like to do but this is impossible
classically and kind of the main reason
for this is that the first verifier you
know the the initial verify that you
started with it runs out of random bits
to use to perform these you know complex
form these verification queries so this
is where the quantum mechanics comes in
so this games like the CSI should CH SH
game that I had described you know not
only does it certify the presence of
quantum entanglement it tells you that
the measurement outcomes of the players
when they use this entanglement are
random okay they have to necessarily
generate fresh random bits and by using
games like you know non-local games like
these we can you know generate more
random bits than what you started with
which can be used for this recursive
verification procedure
so that's kind of the outline of the you
know the proof from a thousand miles
away so you know what are some of the
consequences of MIP starting pool sorry
well I mentioned that it implies this
con embedding conjecture is false but
there's different ways of interpreting
you know the implications of it so you
know for the operator ology algebra is
world it implies that there exists these
von Neumann factors which you know can't
be approximated in some sense about
finite dimensional matrices all right
these extremely complicated objects from
mathematical physics point of view it
implies that there's in principle an
experiment to verify whether nature is
infinite dimensional okay so it doesn't
spell out how to perform this experiment
but it says it's a priori not impossible
and interpret in through
of complexity theory it says that
there's an efficient interactive proof
for the halting problem which is kind of
wild
so here I should mention you know I've
gotten this question a lot and I thought
it'd be a good chance to address this
frequently asked question that I get is
does this MIP start equals re result
mean that quantum computers can be used
to solve the halting problem and the
answer is no you know what it really
means is that you can interactively
verify in constant time whether Alice
and Bob know the result of an
arbitrarily long computational process
but in order for Alice and Bob to
convince the verifier they would need to
you know first of all run this
computational process themselves so they
would need enough resources to do this
and they would need a sufficient amounts
of quantum entanglement but if they had
that then they could verify it they
could you know prove it to you you a
verifier in constant time okay but it
doesn't mean that in constant time in
order you know you can solve the halting
problem okay so there's a question from
de reach how do you see them the math
physics implication so right so I didn't
explain you know what is the connection
between you know how this connects to
the infinite dimensional entanglement
but the game's G sub M that we construct
have the property that no matter what
Turing machine you started with whether
it halts or doesn't halts with infinite
dimensional entanglement you can win
with probability 1 whereas if the Turing
machine doesn't halt any finite
dimensional strategy can only succeed
with probabilities say less than 1/2 so
it says in principle there is a way to
to distinguish between the two cases
you can run sort of a bell test for you
know if you if you play this game and
you see with for some Turing machine M
that never halts and you see that the
players are consistently winning 100% of
the time it tells you that they can't be
using finite dimensional entangled
I hope that made some made sense okay so
this brings me to the end of my talk and
I'd like to end with a parable that
you've probably heard of so in this
story there's a group of blind men who
encounter an elephant for the very first
time the first blind man who has his
hand on the elephant's side says that
it's like an enormous wall the second
blind man who's you know wrapping his
his arms around the elephant leg
you know exclaims that surely it must be
a gigantic tree trunk
the third blind man feeling the
elephant's tail you know thinks that
it's a giant rope and you know these
these blind men argue with each other
and they vehemently disagree but after a
while they come to realize that you know
while each person is partially correct
they each were only seeing local views
of something much more complicated and
interesting so similarly there's I think
there's something that's you know
similar going on with em I pieced
articles re now for a long time
different people from different areas
we're feeling their way around to this
giant mysterious elephant so I'm calling
it the Khan embedding conjecture so I'm
calling a Saracens problem others
calling it the complexity of quantum
multi prover interactive proofs and MIP
star equals re is showing us that
they're all connected by the outlines of
this mysterious elephant that connects
all these views and there's certainly
you know something much more waiting to
be seen so with that thanks for your
attention and I'm happy to answer any
questions
all right thanks
a reminder to enter your questions into
the the chat that was a really very
clear explanation of a fascinating topic
that makes contact with a surprisingly
broad set of of areas we we have we have
a question okay
so sorry yes can you explain more by
what you meant by the reason that
composing PCP theorems in the classical
setting to get MIP starter equals or
easin it runs out of random bits right
so so you know let's imagine that you're
a verifier and you have polynomial a
many bits to try to verify some some
proof and since you only have polynomial
a many bits you can at most choose one
out of exponentially many random
locations and so that kind of means that
the sometimes the largest proof size you
can look at is an exponentially large
proof and this is why MIP the classical
MIP is contained in an X bin and you
know an execute is an upper bound on
what you can verify but you can imagine
that if somehow a verifier had access to
a trusted source of many more random
bits that you know it's beyond
polynomial you could potentially verify
a much longer proof say a proof that's
doubly exponential in size and you could
verify much more complicated computation
so so by playing these nominal games
this is essentially you can verifiably
and certifiably get access to a larger
reservoir of trusted random bits that
you can then use to certain you know to
do this proof verification
second second question is I did the
proof not say that since if the qanun
back on embedding conjecture was true
then the halting problem would be
decidable we conclude that the
conjecture must be false right so that
is that is the the chain the reasoning
if so then why can we say that there's
an interactive proof for the halting
problem good so this non-local game G
sub M that it is scribed is it's
essentially an interactive proof because
you know a way to run this interactive
proof is the verifier you get some
Turing machine and wants to know whether
it halts or not so it then computes this
game G sub M which is just a
prescription for what questions to send
to the two players or approvers and when
the prover send their answers back
whether you accept or reject so by just
playing this game and seeing whether you
accept or reject as the verifier you
would there be able to interactively
verify whether the the Turing machine
halted or not and you know this isn't an
algorithm to solve the halting problem
because it requires approvers to to know
the answer to the problem
okay great so if there are no more
questions I just like say big big thank
you Henry that was a fabulous talk on a
really high impact topic oh there
something another one actually has come
up on the Q&A panel oh I see okay so
surge us one how did elements of the
game capture the Turing machine for
example what is the procedure D
correspond to so that'll take another
talk to explain but essentially I mean
maybe the easiest way to explain is to
explain what happens in the classical
case and the MIP equals an X proof you
know the verifier is able to verify the
result of an exponentially long
computation so this decision procedure I
mean this game is really asking the
provers to prepare a very robust
encoding of the steps of this very long
computation in a way that you can probe
locally and check whether the
computation halted or not so so that's
what's happening in the classical case
and then in the in this MIP star case
it's kind of iterating that an infinite
number of times and then - any idea
about the complexity of the solver
algorithm well now we know that the
solver algorithm first of all it doesn't
work because otherwise it solves the
halting problem so yeah let's see then
Ian asks the idea for interactively
checking the halting problem only works
in reality if reality lives in the
tensor product model rather than the
commuting operator model yes that's
right
if if the provers were allowed to share
infinite dimension
don't angle in this commuting operator
model then they would always convince
you that the Turing machine halted
which you know wouldn't be good all
right fantastic
thanks again Henry and I'm really
grateful to you for the presentation and
thanks to everybody for joining us
all right thanks Peter thanks everyone
all right bye bye bye